look I think somehow and and there are a
lot of historical reasons for this
uh gun ownership in this country
uh became a ideological issue and a
partisan issue in ways that it shouldn't
be
it has become sort of a proxy for
arguments about our culture wars you
know Urban versus rural race is always
an element in these issues issues of you
know a class of class and and education
and so forth and so
instead of just taking a very practical
approach like we do let's say for
example with car safety right where we
say all right we got a bunch of
accidents let's
let's engineer roads so that we prevent
them instead of thinking about it in a
very pragmatic way we end up really
arguing about identity and emotion and
all kinds of stuff that does not have to
do with keeping our children safe